an update on that mobile home park where
residents were forced to move due to the
conditions of the property tuesday was
the deadline to leave the desert
paradise mobile home park on the
boulevard in nellis but today some
residents still there as jeremy j ford
tells us had a rough time packing up
it's closing day here at desert paradise
mobile home park where long time
residents must relocate and find a new
place to live
heartbreaking day because all these
people were longtime tenants who must
leave the property property manager
jamie o'may tells me it breaks her heart
to see them go they're putting temporary
housing
where i don't know what's going to
happen to them after that temporary
housing is over because they couldn't
afford
to move out like maggie lunsford-brown
who along with her family is still
collecting her belongings i'm going to a
shelter
that's specifically designed for me
because i'm a cancer patient she says
with only a few families left the park
should be empty by nightfall i'm 95
percent done with my house i just got a
few more things to pack up in the truck
and put in my storage unit before
leaving the property for good this
shouldn't be happening at all it's
happening a lot
it's happening a lot jeremy j ford live
local now